well uh thanks rachel um excited to be
here um got 20 minutes to talk so some
of this might be a little bit rushed so
i just want everybody to know they can
reach out to me there's my contact info
on the slide and it'll be at the end too
if they want me to
elucidate on any of the points that i'm
making so
the title of this this talk is
professional financial reports with our
markdown but first i'll tell you a
little bit about myself
so i'm a data scientist at um a company
called a country farm credit it's a farm
credit um
organization in north dakota
uh we do a lot of egg lending um i'm a
tidy verse instructor through the our
studio education uh group
if anyone has any
need to learn how to just teach in
general better and especially to teach
technology
i would recommend talking to rachel
about it it's a great program a few of
us went through it then it's been paying
dividends so
i'm also the author of the tidy usda
package which um lets you query the usda
survey and census data and then throw
them into nice county and state maps
which are it was kind of a pain doing
that manually so this i use this every
day at work and i'm also author of a
slightly more useful package called
schrute and if anyone's familiar with
the tv show the office
this this package has all the
transcripts from all of the nine seasons
so you can you know you can create
things like like this chart here that
let's that counts how many times someone
said that's what she said and obviously
michael is
the winner here this is also available
in in python and julia
a lot of people like using this package
just to practice nlp and text analysis
um just because it's it's the data set
that you know a lot of people know
pretty well
i also had the chance to use our um this
this spring so we had our second our
second child and we couldn't we couldn't
decide on the middle name so we use i
think it's called baby names a package
and we kind of narrowed it down to
our three names we had and we were
looking at the trends to see how popular
they were just to make sure we weren't
jumping on the bandwagon
so it was kind of a
fun thing to do i still don't know if my
wife appreciated that or not but
hopefully she forgot with all the
pain medicine and stuff
but uh i always like using r in
any way i can and this this project is
an example of you know doing something
that may have taken a few different
technologies in the past like photoshop
and some kind of photo editing thing
you know excel
what have you
and the goal is to make a nice packet
for
a fictional financial industry company
we're calling it black swan financial so
we're
the output of this will be uh three
separate packets one for each branch in
this company and we're going to do it
all in our markdown and
the the kicker is it's all going to be
pdf outputs because html is
arguably a lot easier to do in our mark
down in the pdf
but unfortunately people in the finance
industry still like to print out reports
so we're gonna we're gonna tackle that
and this is what it's gonna kind of look
like
so the key players the the packages that
i'll be going into a little bit uh in
this talk our markdown obviously is
important cable extra
lets us format cables which are a table
format that we use for pdfs it lets us
set things up really nicely i don't know
how i could do this without this package
unless i knew a lot more about text
which i don't
using the rn i think that's how you
pronounce it the rn package which is uh
and i think it's relatively new it's a
nice package that
lets you reproduce your environment on
someone else's computer kind of like in
python or
julia you know it might make um
installing my dependencies easier on
your system because
um markdown dependencies can be can be
painful sometimes
and then we use the glue package to
glue together
bits of sql and things like that and
some strings we use that quite a bit in
this this example
disclaimers
like i've been kind of hinting at our
markdown is it works great when you you
know
install it on your computer and get it
to work in your computer but the minute
someone else has to reproduce it it can
be can be trouble so
um
using if you've never used the rn
package you should just be able to
download the repo from the first page
and hit rn restore which should should
make your environment almost identical
to mine
potentially you might have to run
reinstall tiny text which will fix some
kind of text back-end stuff
and there's more troubleshooting at the
on the readme
i tested this on windows 10
linux mint 20 and and mac as well
okay so this is um kind of the high
level map of what we're going to be
doing i like to think of you know
anything in terms of inputs and outputs
for projects like this so the inputs are
these three branches that we have
for for our company we're going to use
one our markdown document we're going to
iterate over these branches pull data
from a sql database in this case sqlite
database just for you know an example
and then when it's all said and done
we're going to have a pdf for each one
of these branches
with data for just that branch
so i'm going to go through the the four
pages of the documents here then we're
going to jump into the code a little bit
so there's gonna be a front page with um
you know personalized it's gonna it's
gonna personalize this to show what
branch this packet is for
we're gonna have just a really basic
income statement
another another table with a ggplot um
polygon map
just to show you know that you can put
plots in
and then this is the same as the first
income statement it's just a trend so
just kind of grouping it differently
in your process
okay
so get into the code
all right so if you folks can see uh
down here i'm gonna be kind of
navigating this this file structure but
i'm gonna i'm gonna briefly touch on how
i created the data because
if someone else
if you yourself have to create fake data
for a talk like this there's a really
nice package called charlatan
that makes this really simple you can
create fake users fake credit cards you
can
fake geospatial stuff it's really nice
so
for this example we're creating just a
sqlite database um
we're saving in the file structure
we're creating two tables
uh financials so this has kind of the
data you'd see an income statement then
customers one
which was on the
page with the map and we're just writing
that to this table so
just making some simple data
not really important to remember that
but in case you're interested
dive into the r folder
uh so we've got a setup which is pretty
pretty common
i enabled them i labeled the name the
main function that we're gonna run
through main and then we have a little
functions thing that has a few more
functions and there's an arm markdown
folder which has our r markdown
so let's start with the setup
i've got some packages here just calling
them all right there
i'm pulling the current year in month
because
generally when you have like a packet
like this let's just say it's you know
income statements for a branch you get
this monthly so it's we're gonna be
iterating through that
i'm creating my connection to the sqlite
database that i can use later
and
i'm creating my input data frame so this
is the the three branches that we're
going to iterate over so if i run this
i actually already ran it um
it's going to show
it should show
there it is it's going to show the three
branches that we're gonna we're gonna go
over so fargo battlefield and kindred
those are all towns in north dakota
and um so we're gonna run our finished
packet against each of these
so that's the setup
now main this is where all the magic
happens this is where we we source the
setup
the setup file we just talked about we
we have a function that'll create the
reports it'll knit them and then put
them in our directory that we want
and then we have an iterator function so
i'm going to go through this really
quick
so our create reports function
it looks at
this our main markdown report that
creates the packet it's called
reportmaster.rnb in this in this case
we're using the our markdown render
function to take um the inputs that
we're going to pass to this function
it's going to tell us where we want the
the outputs to go
um it's gonna also name name the outputs
uh and then it's uh we're also
specifying the parameters we're gonna
use which uh
or the the it's the magic sauce for this
it lets us iterate over these
these different branches
so that's that's the main function and
one thing i like to do
is use the per possibly function instead
of a try catch so
let's say you have 40 branches and this
packet is huge and it takes two minutes
you know each to do so it's it's a pain
to have to go through 38 of those and
then have it fail and then you're stuck
so this kind of lets you just go through
them and it fails gracefully um
some i have a three-year-old and
whenever he wants to ask me whenever he
asks his mom
or me um to do something that we know he
knows we're not going to say he tries to
be as cute as possible he says you know
maybe ice cream
maybe
you know go for a walk at nine o'clock
at night so that's kind of what i named
this because that's what i'm thinking in
my head
like maybe create reports hopefully this
will work
that kind of helps me around
remember silly things like this
so we're going to take this is kind of
the main generator iterator part of this
we're going to take the input data
so that was the little data frame with
just the three records in it and we're
going to use the per p walk function to
iterate those
those um
these branches over the markdown to
create the outputs
so that's the main r
files now we'll get into the arm
markdown parts of it
so in the past when i would make our
markdown reports
you know it'd be like a thousand lines
long because i didn't know this trick so
and it was just a pain because you'd
just be scrolling and scrolling trying
to find the things you'd be navigating
with the tree and whatnot
but there's a nice way to do this
there's a
little parameter you can call called
child so it lets you knit an individual
markdown document
and place them all together into one
document
so i have a separate markdown document
for each page of this packet so as you
can see
front page income statement customer
trend on the back page
so then the your main page looks really
clean you can kind of organize it better
so as far as the the top matter goes um
i have the parameters that we're going
to use here these are what we're going
to be using to iterate branch month year
i've got a lot of text stuff that i
honestly couldn't explain what it means
or how it works i just know that after
like a week of
you know getting this format the way i
want i had to have these in
this part so it's one of those things
that i can't really explain but it works
so copy it if you want um something that
you might run into trouble with um
if you're on mac or linux is the the
font so i change it to use
a sans serif font and i'm on windows now
so i'm using colibri but if you're on
linux you know use ubuntu or what have
you so you might have an error there if
you just try to run what i have playing
on on mac or linux so i'm gonna
say that
so let's run through each one of these
pages
and
open up so front page
we're taking the parameter branch
and we are
passing that to this function called
create image so there's a
nice
package called
magic and r
that lets you
edit images do whatever in our case
we're going to be
annotating it with
the text that we're going to see in the
front cover so
so this this is just
literally a png of the front page that
we have saved but this part right here
where it says fargo north dakota branch
this is going to be different for each
one of the branches that you know the
next one's going to say belfield and and
what have you so we're going to be
creating this
in our markdown
and
we're using the glue package the glue
glue function to just glue these
these parameters together to create our
string we're going to throw that string
on that image and return it so
it's a nice way to avoid having to use
photoshop or you know some program like
that to create your cover page
so the next page is the income statement
page
which is this one
so it's pretty basic it's just a single
single column i've got the data up there
and as you can see it's grouped by just
different
if i subheadings
in you can see that it's bolded
some certain fields are bolded
and this is the r markdown page to do it
so
we're going to be calling um
rather querying our sql database that we
created in the beginning the sqlite
database i'm using glue again
to select that data from the financials
so
grabbing a data frame at the very top
um and then i'm not going to go into
what each of these are but you know we
have the data frame we want to you know
change it we want to you know make some
new columns you know add up things and
that's what all this is um so basic data
monitoring and at this point you're
going to have data that's that's wide
right so nice and tidy but for something
like an income statement you want the
data to be vertical so
there's a nice function in data table
called transpose that lets you just flip
the axis of your table
before we we finally put it into the
cable so this is where we use cable
extra
and cable extra has a lot of functions
to let you style the table that the way
you want so in this case
um
for each of these rows i'm um
the rows that i'm aggregating on rather
i'm holding them and this pack rose
function gives us this kind of nested
thing you see here which
is um you know pretty common on income
statements
so in a nutshell we're grabbing grabbing
the data from the sql database we're
munching it and then we're throwing it
into
a cable and using cable extra to format
it which spits out you know this nice
looking
page
i'll move on to the next customer page
or the best customer rather
so
this this is a just a simple table
that looks at the top customers sorted
by interest income and then we have just
a nice gg plot that aggregates that by
states and plots it
so
same same idea we're just pulling the
data from the sql database
and we're creating that that top table
and we're just doing the ggplot
and you can obviously put all kinds of
cool
you know graphs and charts on here and
the point of this talk is and show you
how to use ggplot it's to give you the
idea of how you can you know iterate
over
reports like this
so
last important page is the trend which
is identical to the income statement
page
but we're just grouping by the date so
we have um
kind of a
the way you normally see an income
statement with with previous months
there so you can you know look for look
for trends and whatnot
um and you also you
will also notice when you look through
this that this this page is horizontal
and
there's you actually have to write i
think this is text or latex i'm not an
expert on this but um
if you duplicate the my repo you should
be able to just do type this this um
command in
the landscape and then in landscape and
it lets you you know have one page and
all your packet which is horizontal
which is huge because
this is you know
a pain in the butt to try to format to
look really skinny so
then we have just a simple
for the back page i just literally have
the front page
without without all this text on here so
just nice way to bookend the project and
i'm just including the including the png
right there and knitting it all together
piece by
piece this master document
okay
all right so i've only got one minute
left here but um
so what what can you do with this um i
know i went really fast i didn't have a
ton of time but and like i said you can
feel free to reach out to me
or fork my repo or do whatever you need
[Music]
what what really helps is in any
financial institution you have people
usually in the accounting department
that are making excel reports like this
by hand
which you know introduces opportunities
for error opportunities you know
obviously it's a lot
quicker to do things than our when you
know you spend six hours one day
creating this and then you don't have to
touch it you know forever essentially
so it's a good way to pick off these
excel reports and also get people that
um
that maybe are just excel jockeys like
like i was like a lot of us were and
turn them into our developers because
they see what they can do with our
versus with excel
and it really kind of you know gets that
gets the wheels turning
you can also make your own reporting
easier as well so like if you're a data
scientist like me you have to look at
various tables every morning and instead
of looking at these tables
um you know one by one i you know i just
have our mark doing reports that i've
parameterized to
look at certain tables and give me the
data i need so
with that
i feel like i talked really fast so i
apologize but um i think we have maybe
five minutes for questions rachel
yes that was awesome thank you so much
brad um and yeah we have we have five
minutes for questions now i i didn't
notice there's anything in the chat
window yet um
but if you wanna
ask a question there through the chat
window please feel free to go
do so
or even just
ask aloud it looks like a lot of people
are just saying that was great brad
thank you so much great presentation
hey brad if i could ask a question real
quick
um
so
how do you automate this right now is it
off of your like um you're using
something like microsoft task scheduler
or rstudios uh automation or that's an
issue we've run into with with our
markdown reports is
they don't run consistently
and we don't have access to a reporting
server right now
so have you run into that and then how
have you
kind of solved that problem
so
um my day job at egg country it's um a
windows 10 shop so
you know we don't have the best
you know windows isn't my favorite
platform but um what i found to work the
best is if i make a batch file and call
um in this in the case of this project
it would be
you know our script
our main.r so it'd be running my
iterator
page
that's
i try to make
this a whole project like this roll up
just to one call one function call so
let me pull that up really quick
so everything
if i if i were to run this it would run
this whole process that i just just
described and i find if i make a batch
file that does this um that's the best
way to run it on windows 10. um
i like to use you know linux for my
personal things and you know
putting this on a crown job is
is
easier
we don't have our studio connect yet at
my my office but i i think it's a lot
easier to schedule things like like this
with the professional suite of tools i
mean rachel can say more about that
yeah and so with our studio connect you
could just schedule this to run as often
as you needed it too and then email out
to specific people that needed to
receive it or
i'll put a i'll just put a link in the
chat too if anyone wants to look at it
awesome thank you
um another question in the chat is
brad what about requests to drill into
individual transactions do you get these
from your users
so um
so is the question kind of scope creep
based on the report that i've created so
let's let's say we have this income
statement report um i think the question
is you know do we have people asking to
drill into these things further and if
if that's the case yes all the time um
and
that's more of a person management thing
than it than a data management thing but
um with our markdown reports like this
that are spitting out pdfs it's a little
bit tougher because you have to
you know once you have this format down
and it's creating these tables it's it's
a little bit tougher to change them
versus if you're spitting on an html
report you could use all kinds of
different frameworks like gt that let
you drill into things a lot better
so you know you lose flexibility when
you're spitting out to a pdf in my
opinion
there's a few other questions in the
chat trying to read through which ones
haven't been been answered yet
but someone had asked for any
recommendations for learning
latex
books or websites
um
i don't know latex i know um
they are markdown book
books that yui's put out um
maybe rachel can post those in the chat
or something or something but um
the author of our markdown has a really
really good book and
you know i base you know my learning on
making parameterized reports on his
little chapter that he has in there i
just had to expand on a lot because
it was kind of bare bones but um that's
that's where i'd start as far as like
learning latex proper i don't have a
clue
awesome it looks like nick put a helpful
link there too
i think we have time for one more
question
i see luis just asked my question is
more culture related did you encounter
any resistance to start using r for
reports instead of excel
or outdated report writers oh yeah
i tell people you know when i first
started at my current company there was
no one using r there was no one using
any language like this period
and was all excel and it was
you know i was pretty confident in my r
capabilities it was
i'm spreading you know evangelizing
people on telling that you know our is
better because we can do things like
this and you're not going to have people
fat fingering you know errors that you
know cost millions of dollars so
it's um
the evangelism part is is really the
kicker and you have to have you have to
develop people skills and
in the end you really have to show
what's in it for those people i mean
because you and i know that r is
for certain things r is better than
excel right you just have to show the
value and then people get it
awesome thank you so much brad it it's
funny with virtual meetups not like
clapping for everybody so i'm gonna clap
here
but
thank you so much and um we'll have a
few more minutes at the end of the
meet-up for a few other questions too
but if there's anything that didn't get
answered
we can continue using the meetup
discussion
page as well
[Music]
you